[Música]
vamos a nuestra revista de prensa con
Rosa Pérez Mateo en esta mañana Rosa Un
saludo para usted Buenos días Ángela
tenemos todo un debate para abordar en
esta sección que usted le corresponde y
Es sobre armar a Ucrania un debate que
ya está aquí y que ahora tiene que ver
con los aviones casa nos lo cuenta
Armani isaídete en un artículo de Time
efectivamente Y un poco la polémica es
que si bien ya se debatió sobre si el
envío de tanques recordemos que
finalmente se aprobó la semana pasada
escalaría el conflicto Finalmente y se
interpretaría como una coveligerancia
por parte de la otan por parte de Rusia
Pues esta preocupación todavía es más
aguda cuando se habla de enviar
eventualmente aviones de combate no jets
pero se plantea este artículo de time
por qué particularmente Ucrania está
pidiendo ahora aviones de combate cazas
no bien porque de momento la Aviación
con la que cuenta es una Aviación
soviética que no logra competir digamos
con la que tiene Rusia que si bien
también es de la época soviética pues
permite al ejército de Moscú disparar
misiles de largo alcance sin entrar
dentro del espacio del espacio aéreo de
Ucrania sin embargo ni unos ni los otros
ni los ucranianos ni los rusos en estos
momentos llegan a ser tan potentes como
los que fabrican los países de la otan Y
es que Ucrania no solamente está
pidiendo Fighters f15 o f-16 a Estados
Unidos sino que también está interesado
en los eurofighters o en los Rafael de
Francia y las últimas informaciones que
señala este artículo de Time es que
también estaría interesado en submarinos
alemanes bueno Y al igual que en la
discusión con los tanques los países
empiezan a mostrar muy claramente cuáles
son sus posiciones vamos a hablar de eso
con el medio de Hill porque Ucrania dice
que Polonia da unas señales positivas de
que sí podría proveer estos casas f-16
Sí exactamente este sería un poco la
intuición digamos que describió andry
yemar quien es jefe de la oficina
presidencial de Ucrania que escribió en
su cuenta de Telegram Polonia está lista
para pasárnoslo en coordinación con la
otan recuerda también este artículo que
fue Polonia quien presionó a Alemania
para mandar los tanques leopard sin
embargo que también Estados Unidos si
bien al final fue quien acabó
desencadenando el envío de tanques al
mandar también en sus propios tanques
Abraham se ha resistido previamente ya
Estados Unidos a mandar aviones de
combate a Ucrania no recordemos que en
la primavera pasada no permitió la
transferencia de aviones mig-29 de
Polonia a Ucrania por otro lado también
señala este artículo lo que comentabas
Ángela que Alemania considera imprudente
acelerar Esta carrera armamentística sin
embargo
la velocidad de suministro será clave
también la Pues en el desencadenamiento
no de esta guerra lo que decíamos que
distintos países están pues teniendo
opiniones un poco contradictorias
respecto a este tema de los aviones de
combate Y por último este artículo
señala precisamente la posición de
lituania Y es que en una entrevista El
presidente dijo que espero que esta
línea roja si de verdad existe la
demandar aviones y misiles de largo
alcance pienso que solo está en nuestra
cabeza podrá ser traspasada bueno Esta
es la opinión de lituania de momento
vamos a ir hablando uno por uno de los
países porque hace énfasis Precisamente
en esta posición de Estados Unidos que
dice no rotundo exactamente señala que
este rechazo de vaiden es un revés
significativo y potencialmente terminal
para la campaña de kiev para conseguir
aviones de forma rápida no y vuelve a
insistir de Gary en que Estados Unidos
finalmente fue quien lideró la decisión
del envío de tanques que había más o
menos bloqueado Alemania también señala
que John Kirby del Consejo de seguridad
nacional a este artículo ante otros
periodistas también dijo insistimos en
que Estados Unidos ha mandado más de
27.000 millones de dólares en ayuda
militar a Ucrania no digamos que no es
época cosa señala este artículo también
que la pequeña fuerza aérea de Ucrania
se ha reducido Durante los 11 meses de
guerra y aunque todavía tiene algunos
aviones en funcionamiento tiene una
capacidad muy limitada para enfrentarse
a la fuerza aérea de Rusia y ayudar a
sus fuerzas terrestres a atacar
posiciones rusas atrincheradas y para el
cierre nos sorprende que shortles
también dice definitivamente no en el
medio político lo cuentan exactamente y
hacen referencia en a una entrevista que
dio soles al medio alemán tagger que
decía que no se planteaba el envío de
aviones de combate en absoluto no
también señaló el canciller Alemán que
continuará su contacto con Vladimir
Putin para intentar evitar una escalada
no también recuerda sin embargo político
que al principio la posición de Alemania
a los tanques también era un no rotundo
que Ucrania insistió y que Ucrania
mantiene la esperanza de lo que de
momento es no acabe convirtiéndose en un
Sí pero quisiera recordar una cosa
Ángela no sé si recuerdas que en el mes
de noviembre la cadena estadounidense en
bici publicó una exclusiva que hacía
referencia a una conversa telefónica una
conversación telefónica que habían
tenido bidens que hacía unos meses en la
que explicaban que baiden acabó
perdiendo los estribos delante de la
insistencia de ese lensky para que le
enviara más material militar Porque se
ve que vaiden en ese momento le estaba
anunciando al presidente ucraniano el
envío de nuevo o sea mil millones de
dólares y selensky continuaba
solicitando enumerando una lista de lo
que continuaban necesitando no ibaiden
le dijo Bueno estamos haciendo un gran
esfuerzo nuestro país para enviarles
dinero y armamento bien Vamos a ver
hasta qué punto no también lo salíades
occidentales acaban cediendo a las
presiones de Ucrania o acaban bloqueando
realmente el envío de más armamento
Hasta qué punto podrán aguantar
rápidamente su cierre con la portada de
liberación Sí hemos querido terminar con
este tema de la contestación No las
manifestaciones contra la reforma del
sistema de pensiones propuesto por
Emanuel macron y el gobierno de
Elizabeth Von y vemos Esta portada de
liberación no que dice red Head en las
pensiones toda la galia resiste y la
toda la galia no En referencia a los
cómics de asterix y obelis que
normalmente es un pequeño pueblo de la
galia que resiste a la conquista de los
romanos en este caso dice liberaciones
toda la galia toda Francia que resiste a
la propuesta no de macron que vemos aquí
vestido como Julio César no y es que
precisamente Esta es una de las críticas
que cuando ganó la segunda vuelta
presidencial él asumió públicamente que
a lo mejor había ganado Porque mucha
gente quería impedir que Marín lean
llegara a la presidencia sin embargo
ahora presenta esta propuesta de
reformas legítimamente decidida en las
urnas tenemos que Seguiremos hablando
esta semana gracias a usted Rosa gracias